Robin is in Georgia hey Robin welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show Dave it's such a
pleasure to talk to you today you too
what's up my my wife and I have been
married for three years and I've been a
father review for since I was in college
maybe 25 26 years and so when we were
able to make all of that legal you know
I said let's look at this plan and she
had a we have together about $30,000 in
a bank account savings and all we have
debt wise is we each have a car and I
know it's a little Davis but that was
the compromise it was your way that she
would be on board will start paying off
the debt but I'm going to leave this
money here says like ah well then last
Tuesday her company called her in with
the team and said we're closing our
doors and five to eight weeks they'll be
no severance package there's no vacation
payoff in a company closes store there's
no Cobra and so we're looking at going
down to just my salary until she can
find another job
we each very ironically make the exact
same amount of money or household income
it's two hundred thousand dollars one
hundred thousand dollars each and with
the two car payments and with the
mortgage we can certainly live on my in
conative obviously won't be as much
towards the debt as we've been pay in
the past six months we've been on your
program since June although ish I
apologize so the question is do we takes
$29,000 of the 30 we have in savings
without her working now and pay off we
each owe $20,000 on our car so we have
$40,000 in car debt do we pay that down
and then go from there or do we just
keep that money and make minimum on
everything until she gets another job
and she's 58 so we're kind of close to
well we talked about the olive oil what
does she what she do for a living
she's a merchandiser should be able to
land something then are you in Atlanta
where ya round their yellow south of
there but we we hope that something's
going to happen yeah we got a week
Stefanik job well actually you know what
they said five to eight weeks ago and
there's no like four days the other
thing is they said oh don't tell you
know like people and that's like well
how do you find a job without course a
job or something tell me where you
dumped me on the street I'm gonna go get
a job and I'm gonna leave tomorrow if I
get a new job you don't have any you
don't have any moral obligation or to
sink go down with the ship
so you go get a job you know put
everything on hold no you do not pay
down the debt you're in the middle of a
storm and you put everything on hold you
pile up as big a pile of cash as you can
pile up and then when she lands her job
then you could decide you guys decide if
you're gonna do ish again or not all
this experience will change her mind on
that I mean right now you just push if
you're losing him large behalf of your
household income you push pause on your
Total Money Makeover baby steps
she'll until she lands a job and you
just pile up cash but I don't look I
don't get a job tomorrow I'm not I mean
I wouldn't have a discussion I would I
wouldn't have a theoretical discussion
about this this is you got four weeks
the fuse is burning towards the bomb and
the day I get a job I'm out of that
place
you have zero obligation to them Ithaca
Lee morally or anything else so yeah
then when she real ends the job and
let's revisit the other side of that now
you've got a pile of cash plus the cash
that you've cash you build up during
this four week period of time or
whatever the time is until she lands a
job whatever cash is left over then once
you're both employed again then you guys
have to decide what are you gonna do are
you gonna do ish again and I can't I
know I can't I'm not gonna tell you to
do something other than what I tell
people to do so you need pay off your
stinking cars and you need to do that
immediately it's ridiculous that you
have car payments making $200,000 a year
it's just ridiculous
so you know but you guys got us out how
you're gonna live I can't live your life
for you